[Musica]
oggi i nuovissimi scherzi spiriti storia
rumena uscito un aggiornamento e siccome
gli aggiornamenti per ios quindi
l'iphone non ero certo nel ritardo
abbiamo comprato appositamente un
cellulare android così possiamo giocare
ai nuovi livelli di spiriti sociali
chiedete in continuazione solo che noi
poi dobbiamo aspettare per giocarci ma
non volevamo aspettare
volevamo farvi vedere subito e in più mi
è apparso quando sono andato a scaricare
script in un nuovo gioco e quelli che
hanno votato per i teaser in cui si
fanno solo scherzi e spiriti se non
possono molto più semplice esattori di
duomo questi due scherzi nuovi che
faremo ascheri titolo vi faremo vedere
anche il nuovo gioco vedo l'ora e con il
gioco dei mi piace siamo in debito di
altri gameplay sapete di cosa sto
parlando
l'assaggio mi piace qui sotto e
scoprirete qua a fianco che personaggio
del mondo di spiriti jersey ed è in
questo caso è solo al mondo di scrivi
teaser quindi lasciato mi piace l'ultima
cifra del mi piace che avete passato
corrisponde al vostro personale
scrivetelo anche nei con me
mettetevi comodi preciso corner
iniziamo scherzo ecco qua i nostri due
nuovi livelli catastrofe chimica vediamo
cosa combina
allora si è iscritto il sogno di scritti
licciardi diventare una scienziata sta
per prendere una brutta piega
qualcosa mi dice che saremo noi a far
libertà guarda la con il camice ho
buttato gli occhiali sotto il divano e
allora cosa ha detto ha detto che con le
sue nuove funzioni malefiche vuole fare
tipo delle emozioni velenose non lo so e
ipnotiche ovviamente scheri fisher visto
che sapete che e cattivissima per forza
doveva fare qualche pozione strana
vorrei vedere francis succube ci rimani
con questa pozione che cosa gliela darà
vera francis allora che cosa dobbiamo
fare ma gli sto perdendo un po di cose
così da aprire porte a un trasporta cosa
è qui che lo più il vizio di trovare un
modo per rovinare l'esperimento di
spiriti cr quindi sicuramente sarà
divertente
speriamo tipo di mettere qualcosa delle
pozioni che la trasformi in qualcosa sta
mandando il piede di sopra che cosa stai
cercando e sto cercando delle cose nuove
che ci sono qui tipo d'acqua scala
che cosa vuoi farne la facciamo rosolare
con nell'altro offerto libertà perché ci
credo insomma pertanto un momento che
ripeteranno aggiunto buone cose
che bello scappare con l'asca l'agi ha
cambiato personaggio non subirli ma
siamo tanti infatti lo vedete dalla
maglia rosa da abbiamo messo alla scala
per poter salire sopra dove c'è il suo
laboratorio segreto se l'albero di sosta
dove c'è lo sai che possiamo fare così
perché facendo di via facendo tutti i
suoi introiti da sotto le mentite
chimico io non ci credo non osserviamo
infine di occhiale sintattico e non
avessimo messo gli occhiali non saremo
riusciti sapete che iscritti se devi
sempre stare attento prendere tutti gli
oggetti altrimenti si possa salire in
soffitta segretario non sono tutto
finanziare qua sopra tanta roba scritto
allora fa calda esperimento riuscito
iran
tutto qui mescoliamo di rotta non mi
capire allora c'è acqua calda quella fa
applicare sopra lavagna parte di girarla
acqua calda solidi shop idrogeno però si
ridicolo rosso ci scrive esperimento
fallito uno perfetto lo andiamo a
prendere joe in cucina allora l'idrogeno
perossido appena preso abbiamo
laboccetta qui dove possiamo riscaldare
l'acqua
dobbiamo solo prendere il sapore dei
piatti il colorante in cui si dice che
riportassero elephant to face lo slime
quello gigante ma se avete mai visto
questo esperimento online nel comunque
in pratica esce tutto il dentifricio
fuori si gonfiano veroli che cosa c'è il
senso dobbiamo fare questo però è
fallito quindi che cosa uscirà su canale
con sette campioni a 6 scalandolo quel
bollitore o perché si volevano
accusatore di vedere cosa uscirà su
permesso troverà infatti durante
limitare se lo mettiamo così tutta la
costa d'avorio per piatto ma sterlina ok
quindi giocherò bene 20 fuori non
abbiamo colorato niente dobbiamo nella
parte della croce qualcosa qui allora
chi rivolte come era l'ordine
come era l'ordine ma ovviamente non me
lo ricordo ordine sbagliato a ricordarti
ok ci siamo io ho segnato l'ordine degli
ingredienti per far esplodere
dissi no non so che cosa il primo hub e
siamo sicuri e acqua calda aggiunto dell
acqua calda
poi sapone giusto si pone poi transito
loro sei scappato nella sempre che io sì
dai fan tutte quindi le more ce la fate
gigante li ha travolti tutti e due come
se questo prodotto dai due giganti che
possono solo la migliore scienziata nel
modo di francisca di europa secondo
scherzo game for life
allora c'è scritto quindi iscritti se
vuole diventare una problemi
ma cosa un cancellino
ma che cosa fa allora ha detto di voler
diventare appunto un gamer
professionista e vediamo se si riesce
non ho capito perché vapori stata
avanzata una chiavetta usb sopra un
albero vero nido di un albero quindi
sicuramente sempre nella chiavetta usb e
fare qualcosa non lo so con i dati di
spiriti
forse dovremmo entrare nel suo account
come avevamo già fatto quella volta che
abbiamo fatto nel porto di credito se
avete visto anche di scherzi che abbiamo
fatto al fidanzato di skate teacher
frayling allora ho fatto lo stesso fatto
ecco siamo entrati con su computer
abbiamo comprato prima un delfino poi
una scuola certa non avete visto andate
a vederlo poi alla fine di questo video
porta la teca dei delle loro cose
preziose tra noi brucia fusione
computer con simbolo di sicuro regola
baldi poi che cosa sono quelle banconote
che sono i fumetti di francis chiave
perché così un biglietto con testo in
questo giorno 54 anni fa in questo
giorno circa quattro anni fa si è
arrivata in questo mondo è reso la mia
vita molto meglio essi 6 giugno 2020
bene cartolina di auguri di buon
compleanno bello mi sento che il
compleanno descritti ceres si no
06 54 anni padre 6 giugno che questo
forse può essere un indizio sarà quindi
1966 scrivono password da 6 fino 100 che
cosa te caminetto corri parlando con lo
scotch per che c'entra adesso che cosa
pensi che ti può servire questo vasto
mare ai campi detto guarda c'è la chiave
le chiavi dentro quindi spiriti 6 giugno
a 54 anni certo che se li porta male
una sessantina di anni devono pedata
allora apriamo lo vediamo al computer
un modo di scaricare il virus
forse quello nella chiavetta allora è
vero sprint sulla lanciata allo sciopero
però che strano se questo è un cuscino
rapporto può essere accolta e siamo
passati da te lo se n'è accorto il
cuscino per che cosa dobbiamo santer si
inalbera veramente ho trovato la
chiavetta sull'albero però io ho paura
che si rompa quindi meglio che si è
meglio che usiamo il cuscino per farla
atterrare morbido di l'altro si guarda
questo c'è una fionda prendiamo questa
fionda vedi la prende bene la mia allora
chiavette usb e qui wow
quindi se non avessi messo in cucina si
sarebbero essere avremo fallito esatto
dobbiamo scaricare i virus dal vecchio
computer quindi il becco con tutor ed ha
come motto all'inizio scrittice dicevano
no voglio quel computer perché è che noi
quindi noi prendiamo il virus tavecchio
compito da metterlo color ora siamo
cattivi rischi di diventare una gamers
frasi così in palestre musicattiva
chiamata a bravissimi
e allora prendiamo la chiavetta adesso
perché qualcuno 18 paura che ti arriva
adesso se ne accorge si arrabbierà
tantissimo quindi dobbiamo sbrigarci se
sapete che lei poi va nelle stanze si
accorge che c'è qualcosa che non va ad
ora niente password ok ci arriva ma ci
ha messo la password in automatico ma
non dobbiamo prendere una chiavetta
penso di sì ma sì io la prendo
sì altrimenti le ieri a trento mi sono
sbagliato non dice sempre in sospeso
dice bene quindi abbiamo fatto tutto
quello che dovevamo fare era di fronte
scherzano molto difficile essere
promosso arrabbierà questo nuovo
computer ai virus cosa è trattato tra
computer e entrato nella realtà virtuale
e fornisce va bene cosa è successo
bisogna vigilare tipo risucchiata nei
computer o comunque resta ben rivista
del ricordo l'altra ricovero l'intimo
dello scherzo
ora passiamo al nuovo zoom ecco qua il
nuovo gioco si chiama teacher press è in
pratica stiamo partendo dal livello 2
perché ora malore ha mettere comunque
praticamente dobbiamo fare gli scherzi
scrittice lo abbiamo varie opzioni in
cui scegliere
però se 616 sbagliata lo scherzo non
riesce mai
eccola che cos'è
un po pagano che ha detto lei la
migliore della migliore ecco ci si
poteva allora deve scegliere o dargli la
frutta secca oppure usare un libro
magico
direi di no
insegnando le borracce palazzo perché
quelle cose che può arrivare a globe
rapidi così ha funzionato gli stati
centro torace ed è scappata bellissimo e
che mi ha insegnato solo agire per la
minore sentito il pappagallo che te li
sei parà lacci contatto
aosta suonato il pianoforte sta
benissimo ha detto che sono reso sono
rem piano meglio di media in debito
proviamo con il metronomo trono mo e
pianoforte che linee basiliano le fan e
in più guardando delle osservazioni
[Applauso]
[Musica]
vediamo chi sono questi mostriciattoli
ok dice di rovinarle la tv quindi che
così facciamo tv io dico telecomando un
sì tv sembra troppo scontate come manu
telecomando che speriamo
insomma siamo cazzi vizi che ha
schiacciato sotto il tappeto a perché
col telecomando non funziona quindi li
avrà
ha detto ecco la mia spazzatura che
questi vicini spazzatura quindi a noi ci
chiamò amici spazzatura ma dobbiamo fare
allora
il giornale o il cassonetto il
cassonetto io ti dico ok si cassonetto
dobbiamo spaventarla o con un procione
oppure con un soffio
io ti taglio la ragione si è preso né
amazon virtus stava dormendo
ieri bridge essere il nuovo gioco se
volete che continuiamo con gli altri
scherzi fatecelo sapere nei commenti
esse non avete visto discorsi episodi
scritti 0 scheri stranger oppure la
maestra bulla in cliccate su una di
queste quattro cartelline per andare a
vedere il cancro su quella che preferite
una visione ciao